thanks for you know allowing me to be
here I'm Christa watts I teach in the
math department at the Military Academy
West Point which is just a wonderful
collaborative place to be to give you an
idea of sort of how we collaborate on
everything I was one of the people sort
of dragging my feet may be the only
person dragging my feet to give Jared a
song and a fun fact and so some of that
guys that I work with yesterday during
lunch including dusty Turner who some of
you may know he has spent their lunch
break brainstorming to try to come up
with anything fun that you know I've
ever done apparently I'm not a very fun
person so they even help out with that
and so here some of you might recognize
if you're here last year the map on the
right these are Dusty's are runs so this
way we didn't really collaborate we have
his are run before last year's
conference we have the one at the joint
stats meetings in Vancouver and then the
one on the right which I bailed on a
couple days ago is an hour run at West
Point where we work so if you turns out
if you start at the football stadium
loop around the intramural fields and
end up at our building it kind of kind
of looks like a skinny little R so today
I'm gonna talk about using statistical
methods to estimate coefficients and
allometric models so allama tree is just
a study of the relationship between body
size to things like shape anatomy
different biological measures and
there's a variety of fields that they're
important in a variety of applications
I'm gonna talk about these three but for
instance I have a thesis student next
year who's going to use these same types
of models to look at preventing injuries
and cadets so we have a lot of data you
know all right
so the first one we were looking at
allometric scaling of weight to height
into asian populations and so most of
you are probably familiar you know what
body mass index is BMI it sort of
normalizes height to weight in the sense
that if we have someone who's four foot
ten and weighs 160 pounds and someone
who's six foot ten and weighs 160 pounds
we don't really want to make a
head-to-head comparison of those weights
and so BMI scales actually weight too
high
squared and it's used to classify
adiposity or obesity and overweight
status and so we all probably know
someone who's like you know got a BMI of
35 and 0.4 percent body fat or something
and we say well then I was BMI really
cuz it's not body fat percentage right
it's just it's just a proxy for that but
it turns out that in Caucasian
populations BMI is actually very highly
correlated to body fat percentage so
it's not perfect but it is a good
measure when you know it height and
weight are relatively easy to measure
compared to buying your actual body fat
percentage but it hasn't really been
tested much in Asian populations and so
this paper looked at answering a number
of questions these are sort of the two
we want to look at does weight scale the
height squared so is BMI a good measure
of body fat percentage in Asian Indians
and dude is the relationship the same
among different Asian Indian populations
so specifically we're looking at tribal
populations versus the general
population and so the data that we had
was from two different large nationwide
studies one that was back in the 60s
anthropologic Survey of India and
another more recent study the National
Family Health Survey we've got almost
44,000
adults aged 15 to 54 in the data but
only males so that's you know one sort
of big weakness of the of this analysis
in India cultural norms still make it
hard to collect this type of data on
women and so we only have males in our
in our study and there's lots of
information in this data we the three
that we ended up being interested in
were height weight and then tribal
status and so you know the the top model
here is sort of the basic allometric
model where on the Left we have some
sort of biological variable in this case
weight on the right we have a power law
model with some body measurement in this
case height and so if if I was talking
to a group of doctors I'd leave the
epsilon off but you know that's that's
there so to indicate that we are
actually our goal here is to estimate
the Alpha and the beta
in that model and if we're lucky and the
epsilon turns out to have a log normal
distribution then we can log transform
the model and we have just a simple
linear regression model and then the
other model that we wanted to fit
accounted for tribal membership so we
have T is just a vector zero and one's
indicating what what tribe you're you
are a member of or that you're from the
general population and then if that ADA
vector is all zeros then we say that the
scaling coefficient is consistent across
all tribes in the general population
and so here's my sort of obligatory art
code a Jared set me up so perfectly for
this I'm he gave a lovely talk about our
then and now and you will probably see
I'm stuck in the then I'm trying to
change you might notice I I parent Lee
was pretty optimistic I was gonna used
apply are and then I assume dusty wasn't
it work that day and so I just went back
to what I know and base are but I'm
trying to come around and so you know
here we just basically assigned tribal
membership to the log transform fit a
couple models did an app test and found
that yep in fact we do see a difference
in those two models that were on the
previous slide but what was what's the
takeaway what's the bottom line
there are unadjusted power beta in that
first model was two point zero eight so
very close to two so it looks like you
know in general BMI is a pretty good
assessment of the the relationship
between height and weight even in Asian
Indians after we adjust for tribe our
beta was two point zero nine one of the
33 tribes in our data 24 had
statistically different coefficients but
they ranged from about one point eight
six to two point three five so if we had
you know beta plus ADA we end up with
something in that range and so our the
obesity researchers that we work with
said you know these are close enough we
would consider this a two so yeah
they're statistically different but for
practical purposes BMI seems to do an
okay job even in all of these tribes
alright so that was a pretty basic study
we had collaborators in India that were
actually interested in answering this
question and I
she started out as a student project the
student did it for his senior capstone
and you know then we sort of cleaned it
up some to be published but so now I
want to move into something that I
consider a little bit meteor or at least
to me this is this is pretty interesting
so I said before BMI is a pretty good
indicator of body fat percentage in
Caucasian populations I'm going to
caveat that and say adult Caucasian
populations and so right here we have
the CDC growth curve so maybe if you're
a parent you've seen something like this
in at the pediatricians office and
they're used during wellness exams for
instance and some schools use some to
classify adiposity in children and
adolescents so on the horizontal axis we
have age in years on the vertical axis
we have BMI and then we have these
different bands and so the green band is
what's considered normal weight yellow
gives us a classification of obese or
sorry I've overweight red obese and then
the sort of tan color at the bottom is
underweight and so for instance I go to
the pediatrician with my daughter and
she comes up in the fourth percentile
and they say you know well she's
underweight I have a pretty laid-back
pediatrician I tend to be pretty
laid-back pediatrician looks at and goes
you know she's healthy don't worry about
don't worry about her BMI but that's not
necessarily always the case there can be
very real consequences from this a lot
of states sent home letters for instance
from school if your child is considered
to be overweight or obese and so you can
imagine that parents and pediatricians
are treating or or changing their
behaviors because they think that their
child is overweight and if BMI isn't a
good measure of your actual body fat
percentage then you know maybe they're
treating a problem that doesn't exist
another example that I'm personally
aware of is a child who whose parents
are divorced and mom has custody and a
letter comes home and says he's obese
and dad's married to a pediatrician and
is now using that the fact that mom
under mom's care you know timmy is obese
and he's
for custody of the child so we you know
there are real-world ramifications for
getting this wrong additionally this was
a little disturbing to me I'm you might
notice these bands were determined by
percentiles and that is actually how we
classify obesity and children and so
based on this five percent of the
population of the children and
adolescents will always be obese and 15
percent will always be overweight or
obese and so they're not tied to any you
know anything with that with proven
health outcomes and so you know I went
back and sort of questioned my
collaborators the the doctors that we
worked with on this and like yeah I know
it's a really not a smart way to do it
but this is how it's done
so you know and then the last thing is
probably most people in this room can
look at this track and kind of get an
idea about what's going on pretty
quickly but you're a lot more used to
working with data and graphics then
perhaps the American population in
general and so this is tough because the
cut-offs for BMI change as as you age
for kids and adolescents and so it's
these it's just not accessible to a lot
of parents to be able to look at this
and immediately understand what's going
on
and so because BMI is not stable across
ages so some previous work done by my
collaborators showed that weight doesn't
scale to height squared in adolescents
so in other words BMI is not a good
indicator of body fat percentage in
children and adolescents and they
proposed a tripod roll mass index so TMI
is just weight divided by height cubed
and they found that that did estimate
the body fat percentage better than BMI
I got involved because they there were a
couple of mathematicians a computer
scientist and an MD working on this and
they wanted to look at what is the
actual optimum scaling coefficient so
they said hey what if we cubed it we
think that might be better
that it is but is it the optimal and so
that's what we're trying to do here is
see you know is is cubed optimal can we
find an optimal scaling coefficient and
optimal define two ways one is that it
best predicts body fat percentage so if
we minimize them the miss classification
and then a secondary goal is we'd like
for it to be stable across ages so we
can use the same cutoff for a
five-year-old as an eight year old as a
thirteen year old and so our data all
came from in Haynes data and maybe it's
a lot of you are probably familiar with
it this is a huge survey new data comes
out every couple of years by the CDC
there's tons of information in there you
know in the survey so you know obviously
only looking at a small subset of it but
there there are some it's not a nice
simple random sample and so this is
really when they came to me we've got a
weighted sample so certain
subpopulations are up weighted and over
sampled there are there is still our
thirst of values missing in the data but
a lot of the clinical data is imputed so
the CDC provides five imputed data sets
so you've got you know if you want to do
this rate you need to work with those
multiple amputations and then the thing
that was the most challenging for me was
we had this complex you know sampling
design of course they didn't just
randomly pick ten thousand people from
across the u.s. to sample they have
primary sampling units which means we
need to consider that in our analysis
and so the they were coding all of this
in Python and they originally came to me
and said can you give me you know kind
of tell us what's going on how can we
calculate this and so I kind of gave
them some tutorials in R and said you
know here's how we can account for these
different things in R and if you want to
do it in Python you know you can figure
it out and so I am pleased to say that
you know after a little bit of trying
they came back and we did in fact do the
analysis in R and so I think oh and we
had about 12,000 adolescents over eight
surveyors here
this data and so you know this is just a
sample snippet of code but with a survey
package and our you know it's it's very
simple you've got to just maybe pay a
little bit of attention to what your
your parameters are for your functions
but it's pretty pretty easy to do
someone else has put a lot of work into
this package and so you know they were
happy at this point to to take a punt I
guess and so what were the results on
the left we have a scale that that the
horizontal access is that the index of
the exponent so going from one which
would be a linear relationship all the
way up to height to the fourth power and
the band shows the the vertical axis is
the misdiagnosis rate and the band shows
areas that are not significantly
different from the best and so we see
the absolute optimal scaling power is
2.9 and and 3 was was no different than
2.9 from a statistical perspective and
we're interested in the blue line and
gives us if we use the same cutoff for
all ages the green line down below says
if we look at each two year age group
separately in design separate cut-offs
and of course we can do better in that
case but we're still doing better than
BMI even with the blue line and then on
the right what we actually have is now
on the and both of these are males only
so there are different cut-offs for
males and females
on the right we have on the vertical
axis their age and on the or sorry on
the horizontal axis and on the vertical
axis we have the 50th percentile so what
we're what we want is as we go across
age we would like for the 50th
percentile to be relatively consistent
if I could be like all percentiles to be
relatively consistent and we can do the
85th or the 95th or the 5th and we get
very similar graphs and so if we look
sort of the third solid line from the
bottom is TMI the second from the top we
have BMI and we see that TMI does stay
much more consistent across ages so
that's you know the secondary goal that
we
looking for is also it's also beneficial
to use TMI instead and then the third
project is looking at height versus all
of these different body measurements and
so it could be your head height or your
head circumference or your sitting
height or your wingspan and we had a
collaborator that's a biologist that was
interested in understanding how those
different measurements scale to your
height so X in this case is you know any
number of different measurements and one
of the the folks working on this
actually on all of these projects I got
through Diana Thomas is a mathematician
in our department that used to run an
obesity research center and the the
equation on the Left should look like
something that we've seen before if the
errors are additive on the log scale we
can fit that as a regression model and
you know hopefully things aren't too
challenging but after going back to the
collaborator a few times
John Speakman so biologists on this we
realized what he's actually interested
in is understanding which of these two
is the right form so if this if these
different body measurements scaled to
height differently for men and women how
is it differently for men and women and
so the graph on the right where we see
just sort of a shift but the slope
remains pretty consistent across head
height but there's a shift up for men
and these by the way this these are just
made up numbers nobody's like 500
centimeters tall and are in our data I
just wanted to show there's different
shapes that we were interested in and so
the graph on the right if that's the
true relationship is an indication that
this change is an evolutionary change
and so women and men have evolved
differently but now we actually see you
know something pretty consistent within
our different measurements and so for me
from a statistical perspective this was
a really interesting thing to fit
because on the right you know first I
tried to do some convincing that we
didn't really need to fit that model
because I wasn't really sure what to do
with it and then I realized well we can
just turn it into an additive error
model and let's just try and see maybe
if we have normally distributed errors
and
still in the middle of this analysis but
I don't want to give you the punchline
so our data here came actually from
basic trainees and so we have army basic
trainees at Fort Jackson South Carolina
that's most of our support branches go
through Fort Jackson all Air Force
initial entry training occurs at
Lackland Air Force Base so we have these
human solutions 3d body scanners we've
got almost 10,000 soldiers at Fort
Jackson and over 65,000 at Lackland and
one of the nice things here is you know
there's nowhere near 1/3 of the army our
feet of female soldiers but all of 60%
of female soldiers do their initial
entry training at Fort Jackson and so
we've got about a third of our sample
that's actually female and so you know
we just write up a little nice little
likelihood function we use the optimum
to try to actually maximize or minimize
the negative log likelihood because that
seem to be a little easier the only
trick here is to kind of have to have
good starting values but this function
is gonna solve numerically so if you
start off somewhere that's unreasonable
you're you know the bad things are gonna
happen
so getting the variance a good place to
start for the variance takes a little
work but the worst this is still in
progress but so far you know the models
have actually fit very well to the point
that I thought I had made a mistake in
the first one cuz it's the error
structure looked so normal that I acted
that call someone else into my office to
check my work and make sure that it was
it was right so what are the results
stay tunes and those are just a couple
other papers that that we've worked on
you